*Some spicy jams*
*More Spicy jams*
Oh
I don't care who you are. I don't care what games you like but if you don't groove at this intro
you're doing it wrong ah
Welcome back everybody to Doki Doki
Cinnamon club *Literature?*
Literature Club, thank you. We're gonna keep playing and
I highly recommend if you're a new that you go and check out part 1 this is a game with  build up
You know you gotta get there you know we know we have to go through a certain point for things to get things (absolutely)
But you gotta get there to experience the full range of emotions really well-written
Really well done so far. I'm really enjoying playing this game. I'm trying to romance Yuri in this section
You have to pick words to make Yuri happy which is the purple girl?
*I think we know this pewds*
Disaster hey, she like that who would you romance, who's your favorite girl?
Tragedy! Oh she likes tragedies okay who likes climax?
I kind of want to click that just to see, hey! Yuri confirmed best girl
*Random Pewds Noise*
Wrath, she likes that too and frightening, she likes that too. I know what my bish likes (Christian channel)
That's right. I treat her right. She like socks. Okay, nevermind
*Pewds Mating Call*
Disoriented, disarray, contamination, uncanny
*More Mating Calls*
Doki Doki Doki Doki is the sound of the heart I think. Marzia told me
Graveyard. Like we say duh deun duh deun (lol the hell)  they say Doki Doki
Those crazy Japanese, am I right?
And I shouldn't have said that. No, okay, um sadness, what? anxiety, crimson,
Cage, misery. What the.. I don't... okay all right.. suicide, yeah!!!!
Intellectual, who watch Rick and Morty? hey Yuri confirmed best girl come on get real here
Raindrops, damn, I really nailed it
"Another day passes and it's time for the Club meeting already. I'm really excited to go to the club"
"I've always wanted to be part of a club in a school. So this is great for me"
"I've gotten a little more comfortable here over the past couple days"
"It's been two days by the way, entering the club room, the usual scene greet me"
"Hi Pewdsiepie"
"Yo Sayori looks like you're in a good mood today."
"hehehehehehe I'm just still not used to you being in the club. That's all"
"I see. That's a pretty simple thing to get you in a good mood, but I guess it's always the simple things with you anyway"
uh, sorry, one second sumimasen hello
speaking of... "SPEAKING OF WHICH.."
"I'm kinda hungry..."
"Will you come with me to buy a snack?"
"No, thanks"  WOW
" Ehhhh?? That's not like you at all." "I have my reasons"... what is my reasons?
"Why don't we take a look at your purse Sayori?"
City City no reason really I just wanted to look at it hey
Sorry nervous lead retrieves her coin purse
She fumbles with the latch and gets it open
Then she turns it upside down and lets its contents belong to the desk only two small coins fall out
Oh, I see, okay. Okay? I
Knew it I could see right through so you're a big beer. How did you even know?
It's it's simple
Also, I talked to Ken about the game a little bit
Ken has played the whole game already. He said he didn't spoil anything
But I
I went into the folder of the game
He didn't spoil this either. I just felt like checking it out cuz it's that kind of weird game
Let's see if I can find it one second
Maybe you don't care
Look I was just fucking around. I'm like okay wait. Why is the characters?
Why do they have an individual file?
That's weird, and what happens if I delete the file
so I
made a copy of them just in case my precious girls if
You had enough money in the first place you would have bought a snack before coming to this club room so either you're not hungry
And want an excuse to take a walk
Or you plan to conveniently forget that you spend all your money so that I would lend you some, but there's one more thing
You're always hungry, and so that only leaves the one option
It made me feel guilty
If you feel guilty that means you deserve to feel guilty
That makes sense ha ha ha ha
You recently giggles?
hey, I
didn't notice she was listening in her face is in her book as always ha ha I
Wasn't listening to anything. I was just it was just something in my back
Let me borrow some money, that's
Don't get me involved like that Sayuri
Besides you should only buy what you can responsibly afford. She's so responsible and
Frankly after pulling a mischievous little stunt like that
your suffering is fair enough retribution your suffering ah
Did I just I didn't mean that I got too absorbed into my book
I
Really like we need speaking mein Yuri. He didn't even meet spirit if in theory, that's
There's no way you could think that you
Were ready and easily paid you mean we have to keep the revolution the revolution
retribution bit
He'll come in from you saiary. I
Guess there's a little devil inside of all of us isn't there?
foreshadowing everybody
Don't let her fool you
Minute in case people are saying like also you already know. It's gonna be a creepy game. It's pretty obvious
Just reading the reviews of the game or anything like that you can't avoid it going in but either way
I'm enjoying it even though. It's a regular story based game so far and
No hint for it to technically be a horror game
Just a random thought Sayuri knows exactly what she's doing
after all she told you guys she was bringing me to the club before she even told me but
You in it Kim if it weren't for the Cape Cate, so we had to trick netsuke Jamaican, dude
Come on. Give me some credit. Give me more credit than that Sayuri I
Just
slap her oh
Wow, yeah I don't know where Oh something smack say you're in the face and tumbles
Cookie sure enough it's a giant cookie rat in plastic. It's they I forgot her name night
Participate mini restitution
Reduce retribution actually that one almost worked very mad Sookie. That's it I
Was just gonna give it to you, but then I heard you blab about the cupcakes. It was totally where I've seen your reaction
Fiery hugs the cookie geez just eating Sayuri rapidly tears open the wrapper and takes a big bite
Sure good
Say or II suddenly clasp her hands over her mouth and pity me tea
You're going through a lot over just one cookie
My name is Mickey Mouse
Nats Iggy takes a bite of our own cookie
Hey, you look really good - Nikki Guinea tree
Cheese beggars can't be choosers. Uh-huh, but yours is gently
Yeah, but do you think I gave you that one? Why do you think I gave you sorry they?
Really hate me Sheamus win with me he
Say or he gets out of her seat and goes behind netsuke. Then wraps her arms around her. That is so cute
oh geez oh geez Rick I
Get it. I get it cookie still in hand not to get reaches up to nudge say Orie offer. I'm her
Fairy suddenly leaves down and takes a bite of Nancy Keys cookie. Hey, did you seriously just do that?
Mouthful say or it rots away to save me Yuri, and I laugh as well jeez you're such a kid subtabs
Monica can you tell Sayuri?
Hey, that's the gig Lance's ran Monica isn't in the classroom, huh?
Where's Monica anyway?
good question
Have any of you heard have any of you heard anything about her being late today eat me
Yeah, I haven't either
Hmm, that's a bit unusual
Okay
Of course she's okay. Ha ha
She probably just had something to do today
She's pretty popular after all
Mmm. You didn't think she sees heaven
Ha ha I wouldn't be surprised
She's probably more desirable than any and then all of us combined
Excuse me
Suddenly the door swings open
Semi, messy, I'm sorry. I'm super sorry ah
there you are I
Didn't mean to be late. I hope you guys weren't worth it or anything. Yeah
Monica choose the clip every boyfriend and
Your sister Yngwie
What boyfriend what an F. Are you talking about?
Monica quizzically glances at me
Never mind that what held you up anyway ah
Well my last period today was study hall I read that wrong in my head to be honest
I kind of just lost track of time
That makes no sense though
you would have heard the bell ring at last at least I
Must have not heard it since I was practicing piano
piano I
Wasn't aware you play music as well Monica Wow Sugoi desu Nia she is so amazing
Monica ha I don't really I
Kind of just started recently I've always wanted to learn piano
Okay
You should please do be pretty to me Nicky
that's
Monica looks at me, maybe once I get a little better. I will
That sounds cool
I'd also look forward to it. Is that so in that case I
Won't let you down bean soup. I Wow they all want me so bad. This is just like real life for me guys
Anime babes left and right you don't understand my struggle
Monica smiles sweetly ah
I didn't mean any pressure anything like that ah
Don't worry. I've been practicing a whole lot recently, and I'd really love the chance to share once. I'm ready I
see in
That caves best of luck
Thanks
So I didn't miss anything did I?
no, not not not really I
Chose to leave out sailors mischievous escapades, I'm sure not to give away enough complaining to her in any way
It looked like everyone has already settled down
Say already some I already finished her entire cookie URIs back to her book and Natsuki disappeared into the closet
I'm really curious to talk to URI a little bit more
but at the same time I would feel bad for distracting her from reading I
Catch a glimpse of the cover of her book it looked like the same book that she led to me
More than that she seemed to be on the first few pages oh
Okay, so this is because we did correct with the diary. I mean the poem. I don't know what it is
Huh
Crap I think she noticed me looking at her
She sneaks on another glance at me and her eyes meet for a split second
But that only makes her hide her face deeper in her big
Sorry, I was just spacing out. I'm not under this sensing. I made her uncomfortable oh
It's fine if I was focused and I probably would have noticed in the first place
But I'm just rereading a bit of this so
That's the book you gave me right
Hmm. I want to read read some of it. I wanted to reread some of it not for any particular reason
sure Yuri sure
Just curious how come you have two copies of the same book? Oh did she buy the book for us?
You reach the best girl huh well when I stopped at the bookstore yesterday?
That's not what I meant
Confer I mean, I just happened to buy two of them ah I say
There's something fairly obvious here that you're isn't telling me, but I decide to let it go. I'll definitely start reading it soon
I'm glad to hear once it starts to pick up you might have a hard time putting it down
It's a very engaging and relatable story
It's that so
What's it about anyway?
well
hmm
Yuri closes the book and scans her eyes over the back
The book is titled portrait of Marco
Okay, it's not an actual
No it is Boris Boris
Custard you
Know that's a painting oh
Well
There's an ominous looking eyes symbol on the front cover oh
Wait alright, I just wanted to make sure I didn't I don't accidentally give anything away
Basically, it's about this girl in high school who moves in with her long-lost younger sister
But as soon as she does so her life gets really strange
She gets targeted by these people who escaped from a human experiment prison and while her life is in danger
She needs to desperately choose who to trust
No matter what she does she ends up destroying most of a relationship and her life starts to fall apart
That's kind of
That's kind of dark isn't it?
Yura made it sound like it was going to be a nice story so that dark turn came it came from nowhere. Ah
Ha ha URI gently giggles all of a sudden. Are you not a fan of that sort of thing pizza pie
No, it's not that I mean I can definitely enjoy those kind of stories, so don't worry. I hope so
Yeah, I totally forgot that URI is into those things
She's so shy and we close him on the outside, but her mind seems to be completely different
It's just that those kind of stories. They challenge you to look at life from a strange new perspective
When horrible things happen not just because someone wants to be evil
but because they have their own goals in their own philosophy that they won't believe in they then suddenly when you
Thought you related to the protagonist
They made out to be an AE to be the knave one for letting their one-sided morals into
Can't read interfere with the villains plants, and I'm rambling aren't I not again
I'm sorry. Hey, don't apologize. I haven't lost interest or anything well
I guess it's alright then but I feel like I should like to know that I had this problem well
She just described the whole plot as well of the book, right
When I let things like books and writing fill my thoughts I kind of forget to pay attention to other people so
I'm sorry if I end up saying something strange and please stop me if I'm talking too much. That's I
Really, don't think you need to worry that
Just means you're passionate about reading the least I can do is listen. It's a literature club after all ah
That's well. That's true in fact. I might as well get started reading it right
You don't have to
What are you saying just a moment ago you were looking forward to it?
Let me just get the book. I quickly read through the book that I had put into my bag all right
it's fine if I sit here right oh, I
slip into the seat next sliding into the DMS with URI ah
Yeah, are you sure?
You seem a little apprehensive
But that's a I'm sorry
It's not that I don't want you to it's just something. I'm not very used to that is reading in company with someone
Soccer well, just tell me if I end up distracting you or anything
All right, I open the book and start the prologue. I don't understand that you means
What URI means by reading in company?
It's as if I can feel her presence over my shoulder as I read
It's not a particularly bad thing maybe a little distracting, but the feeling is somewhat comforting URIs in the corner of my eye
I realized that she's not actually looking at her own book. I glanced over. It looked like she's reading from my book instead
Semi-matte say I was just you're it you really apologized a lot. Don't you?
I do I don't really mean to
This is sorry I mean
Here this should work right I slide my desk
until it's up against yours then hold my book more between the two of them ah I suppose so
You written timidly closes her own copy once with such cute once we each lean
Yeah, once we actually in a little bit our shoulders are almost touching wow. This is pretty hot stuff here guys
It feels like my left arm is in the way so instead I use my right hand to hold the book open Oh
Put what are you gonna put your left arm, buddy? Ah
I guess this makes it kind of difficult to turn the page is she going to turn the page for us here
Kawaii desu nee Wow
URI takes her left arm and holds the left sided or the book between her thumb and forefinger
How is this gonna be a horror game?
Ah
I
Do the same with my right arm on the right side of the book that way
Oh, yeah, cuz they turn the page the opposite way that way
I I turn a page and you raise slides it under her thumb after
It flips to her side or maybe they inverted the picture, I don't know
But in holding it like this
We're huddled even closer together than before
It's actually kind of distracting me. It's as if I can feel the warmth of Yuri's face
And she's in the corner of my vision. Are you ready?
Hey
to turn the page ah
Sorry, I think I got a little distracted for a second. I glanced over at your face again, and her eyes meet I
don't know how I'll be able to keep up with her ah
That's okay. You're not used to reading right. I don't mind being patient if it takes you a little bit longer
It's probably the least I can do
so cute
Since she's since you've been so patient with me
Yeah, yeah
Thanks, we continue reading. You're ready. No longer. Ask me if I'm ready to turn the page instead
I just assumed that she finishes the page before me so I turn it by my own volition
We continue the first chapter in silence even so turning each page almost feels like an intimate exchange
My thumb gently letting over the page letting it float her over to her side as she catches it under her own thumb. Hey Yuri
This might be a silly thought, but the main character kind of reminds me of you a little bit
You think so
How does she well I guess she's more blunt in a lot of ways, but she also?
Second-guesses all the things that she says in dense
Like she's afraid. She'll do something wrong
it's not like I can seem to your head or anything, but they're
kind of reminiscent of some of your mannerisms I
see
Hillary remains silent for a moment but pizza pay that's probably a
Terrible thing to have in common with her
This is so embarrassing that you think that
Wait I didn't mean in the bad way or anything. I'm sorry. I didn't really know you were self-conscious about that sort of thing I
Guess it means that it's kind of cute, huh?
What are you saying all of a sudden hi, are you calling me cute are you?
Okay everyone I
Think it's about time we shared today's poems with each other
We might have have enough time if we wait too long
huh
You ready exhales spared from finishing her thought
Is that all right Yuri? You look kind of down?
I'm sorry if you haven't been a been looking forward to this. Uh it's not it. It's fine
Yuri Lazer's hand from the book causing it to close on top of might them all right. I guess I'll do some more reading tonight
Or would you prefer? I only read it with you? Oh?
I
Guess I don't have too much of a preference either way read it with her
Hmm in that case I'll read the lib March night
It'll be more fun to read with you after it picks up a bit you know
That's good reasoning. That's actually good reasoning
Yeah in that case feel free to finish the first two chapters in your own tent all right. I'll stand up
I make a mental note or where I left off in that book then slip it back into my bag
It's poem reading time mother gosh Kristin channel
So every everyday finishes with you reading a poem this is the second time read the poems
And it really
Lets you understand their individual personalities more. I think we should start with like we did last time
It's kind of a good order this way. I think so go it's I or II and my god her voice
I'm glad Silvo your tone makes it sound like you like yesterday's better
You know me look too well for my own good
Well don't just try to be nice about it if I'm doing a bad job, then I rather just hear it
no, no I
like this when the premise
You know I would like to you put the pipe never ever
Yeah, I guess so
What made yesterday its poem so great compared to this one then?
Figuring out a sponsor getting paid
But that's why I just go with my heart. If it makes me feel things then you miss be a kid ping
I'm not sure that's exactly how it works then again. I guess conveying feelings is pretty important part of this whole thing. Yeah, maybe
Honestly, I don't even know what kind of writing you like in the first place
Why don't you at least try giving it some thought you want to repeat for me
Yeah, right
But you're always thinking about other people Oh
Click the wrong you need to think about yourself once in a while if you don't you might end up getting hurt at some point
We I don't really new with that what you mean big and a tree to keep eating me well, whatever
Anyway, let's see hmm. I gave you like heavy pain wait sometimes it makes it pretty
Pitiful this is word for that right the weight. I'm looking for melancholy
Happy and sad I can't see you liking something sad scary
You have a little rain plate in your head it can help you keep your
Including me
Sorry that's unexpectedly poetic
Baby
Did you read my poem milky you can meet my partner, okay alright
Parents
I pop off my scalp like the middle cookie Jack
It's a bigger place where I keep all my dreams
little balls of sunshine or rubbing together like bundle of Katie
And reach inside with my thumb and forefinger and black when air is warm and tingly
But there's no time to waste if I put in the butter to keep it safe
And if I put the bottle on the shelf with all of the other parts
Happy thoughts happy thoughts
Happy thoughts a mortal's all in my room my college makes me let the friends each
Bottle a star length to make a mince them times my friends feels a certain way
then comes a band to save the day my
Neighbor
Night after night more dreams friend after friend more battles
Deeper and deeper my fingers call like exploring a dark cave
Discovering the secrets hiding in the nooks and crannies
digging and digging
scraping and scraping I blow dust of my
battlekey's
It doesn't feel like time leaves my empty shell could you some more my friends look through my luck front door
Finally undone I open up and in come a frames and they come in such a hurry
tell me what my bottle says much I
Frantically pulled up from the Shelf what after either hold in the Mart to each and every frame each and every bottle
But every time I let one go shatters against the tile
Between my feet happy thoughts happy thoughts happy thoughts insurance all over the phone
They were supposed to be for my friend my friends who weren't smiley they're all shouting blading
Something but all I hear is echo echo
Iko, Iko, Iko
in famous
It's actually kind of deep I guess she said met metaphorically using the cookie jar as her
Emotions say or did you really write this that's crazy
He might tell you that he was gonna read the paper, baby. Yeah, but I mean I didn't expect something like this coming from you
Monica Monica took me home, and I been really in touch with my feelings
I
See that it's almost kind of creepy
Well not exactly maybe because I'm so used to you being cheerful
Well nevermind. I'm thinking too hard about it the point is it came out good. So you should be proud of it
If he makes I feel like it wasn't meant to express Pete if this week
It even helps me understand my feelings a little bit
Writing. It's like maybe
You got pretty passionate about this huh? I hope you keep it up
Don't get ahead of yourself
So I always always had a habit of getting obsessed with something before dropping it no were than a week later
I wonder this is one of those times, but seeing the passion in her eyes makes it hard for me to be pessimistic
All right
I'm gonna Eureka's. I don't think I can do a high-pitched voice twice in a row. Let's see what you've written for today
Yury stares at the poem with a surprised expression on her face, and do you like it?
pizza pie
How did you pick up on this so quickly just?
Yesterday. I was telling you the kind of techniques worth practicing
Maybe that's why you did a good job explaining
I really wanted to try giving it more imagery imagiro, yuri visibly swallows
even her hands appear sweaty and
Not used to this used to what I don't know
It's fine. Take your time Yuri breeze and collects her thoughts
I know that Yuri likes to think before she speaks so I offer that patience to her
Yeah, just being
Appreciated like this I guess it
Probably sounds really stupid, but sing someone motivated by my writing. It just makes me really happy
Are you saying you never shared your writing before?
Yuri nuts
Really, I don't believe it. I
Really only write for myself and besides people would just laugh at me
Do you really think that?
again Yuri nice
huh
even your close friends
Yuri doesn't respond to that I wonder wife
Anyway, do you want to share the poem you wrote today? Yeah, I do if it's with you oh
My yeah
There raccoon it
Happened in the dead of the night
While I was slicing bread for a guilty snack
My attention was caught by the scattering of a raccoon outside my window that was I believe the first time. I noticed my strange tape
tendencies as an unordinary
human I
Gave the raccoon a piece of bread my subconscious well aware of the consequences
Well aware that a raccoon that is fed will always come back for more the enticing beauty of my cutting knife was to sympton
The bread my hungry curiosity the raccoon an urge the moon
Increments his face and reflects that much more light off of my cutting knife
their very same light that glistens in the eyes of my raccoon friend I
Sliced the bread fresh and soft the raccoon becomes excited. Oh perhaps. I'm merely projecting my emotions into the newly
Satisfied animal the raccoon is taken to following me
You could say that we gotten quite used to each other the raccoon becomes hungry more and more frequently so my bread is always handy
Every time I brandish my cutting knife the raccoon shows me its excitement a rush of blood
classic
Peruvian conditioning I slice the bread and I feed myself again
What some raccoon
and I
Was a little more daring with this one than yesterday's I can see that. It's a lot more metaphorical. Yeah, I
Don't know if it's my fault, but I can't begin to imagine what this poem is about
That's right
It's a bit closer to my preferred writing stack
Using the poem as a canvas to express vivid imagery and conveying emotions through them
Yeah, if I take it at face value, then I can't even figure out what it's supposed to mean well. I
Think it's something that different people can relate to in their own way
I wanted to express the way it feels for me to indulge in my more unusual hobbies
It's those sort of things I usually force to keep to myself
Maybe it's about her writing
So I sometimes enjoy writing about them
Why do you keep them to yourself?
They because they're embarrassing and people would make fun of me. Don't you have anything like that pizza pie?
Well yeah, I guess I do I
Feel like everyone has a little something like that the best we can do is respect each other and our individuality
Even if it's difficult sometimes and some things mixes are uncomfortable
After all if I hadn't learned to embrace my own weirdness I would probably hate myself
I might be renting it a little bit now, but I'm glad that you're a good listener
So sweet so pure so wonderful it's time for Natsuki. I haven't spoken to her much
Hmm, I like your last one better
Hey really?
Well, I can tell you were a little more daring with this foot
But you're really not good enough for that yet. It fell flat wow
She is blood that may be true, but I wanted to try something different
I'm still frigging this all out I
Mean I always like poems that aren't trying too hard
I hate when people try sound fancy made more meaning just by using annoying and complicated language
Just make it simple cute and to the point, it's really funny how
Their their personalities are reflected in their poems and it's really funny how I'm actually
Appreciating that is the game about reading poems with girls. It's so tough
But it's really entertaining
Yuri's head-over-heels for all these cryptic nonsense, but I see right through that bs
Making your reader look so hard for all these deep meaning. It's just an excuse to have no meaning ah I
Guess that's one way to look at it
Well everyone has to want to be but my opinion is the best opinion. I'm sure you figured that out already
Anyway, here's my poem maybe you'll learn something
Ahem believe it if the music changes too babyish Sam Amy likes Amy like spiders
You know what I heard about Amy Amy like spiders geeky wrigley hairy ugly spiders listen why I'm not friends with her
Amy has a cute singing voice. I heard her singing my favorite lobster
Every time she sang the chorus my heart will pound to the rhythm of the words, but she likes spiders
That's why I'm not friends with her one time. I heard my like really bad Amy
Help me up and took me to the nurse
I try not to let her touch me she likes spiders so her hands are probably gross
That's why I'm not friends with her amy has a lot of frames
I always see her talking to people she probably talks about spiders. What if her friends start to like spider steel?
That's I'm not friends with
It doesn't matter you see has other hobbies. It doesn't matter if she keeps it private
It doesn't matter if it doesn't hurt anyone. It's gross. She's gross the world is better off without
spiders
I'm trying to think of it if it's something and
My mind went to that Amy likes other girls or something like that like you know how some people are
Really against that sort of stuff or because she likes her, but she doesn't
Like this part of her
That she thinks is really filthy
not bad, right
It's quite a bit longer than yesterday's yesterday's yesterday's was wait tissue. I was just warming up
I hope you didn't think that was the best I could do
No, no of course not anyway the message. It's pretty straightforward in spun. I doubt I have to explain it
Sometimes you can explain complicated issues with much simpler analogies, and it helps people realize how stupid they're being
Yeah, yeah, that's true
Like anyone would agree that the subject of this poem is an ignorant jerk
Do you know do you know people like that of course? It's about it. How everyone thinks my?
It doesn't matter it can be about anything
Is it about our handwriting I
Wrote it to be easier to relate to never ask some kind of weird hobby or guilty pleasure okay? Wasn't as deep as I thought?
Something there. You're afraid if people find out
They make fun of you or think less of you
But that just makes people scalping
Who cares what someone likes as long as they're not hurting anyone it makes them happy
I think people really need to learn to respect others for liking weird things
Huh that's funny you rewrote about something similar today
huh
Did you say Yuri yeah?
she sent her poem was about unusual hobbies of hers I
Didn't really get it, but she said something similar to you
That's that people shouldn't be shouldn't make each other feel insecure about those things really
Well, I mean Yuri's pretty weird, so I wouldn't doubt that she has come some weird hobbies
Not that there's anything wrong with that
Did she just expose herself with her own poem it's not like I would judge her anything
Matt's like he has trouble finding words. I guess that she try not to be something
That's funny
If she feels insecure about her we had behavior system
I mean, how was hate people who make me feel insecure, and you remain me feel insecure yesterday
But but the way you put it it sounds like she's learning her Lucy
Well, I would say so even if your writing style is really different. I'm sure she'll appreciate the message in your poem
It's what I do best after all I don't like writing a list. There's a good message to take away from me
Like conveying emotions is important, but I want to make people think not just feel
It's really interesting hearing there are different perspectives on writing because I when I when I hear her talk nut City
That's a good talk. I really agree with her and what she's saying, but when I hear you explain her perspective
I really agree with what she's saying as well, so it's really interesting
Remember they I'm gonna read a good poem for tomorrow - so look forward to it
Who should I show my poem to next Monica
Hi again Pittsburgh, what's the writing? How's the writing going alright? I guess
I'll take that as long as it's not going back. I'm happy you're applying yourself
maybe soon you'll come up with a masterpiece I
Wouldn't count on that you never know what?
To share what you wrote today for today sure here you go. I get my poem to Monica
Alright great job pizza Bank. I was going oh in my head while reading it. It's really metaphorical
I'm not sure why but I didn't expect you to go for something so deep I guess I underestimated you
It's easiest for me to keep everyone expectations low that way it always counts when I put in some effort
That's not very fair. Well. I guess it worked anyway
You know that Yuri likes this kind of writing, right?
Writing. That's full of imagery and symbolism
unlike Sayuri who likes using simple and direct words to describe happiness and sadness
Yuri likes it when readers are left to derive their own meaning out of it
It's very challenging to write like that effectively
Both allowing people to get something out of it just feel
Or letting them deeply analyze all of the nuances
It can take years of practice which I'm assuming Yuri HESA as at this point. I never really asked though
I'm sure I'm nowhere near her level yet. Don't worry so much about that
You do your own thing just keep exploring and learn by trying new things, but anyway you want to read my poem now
I like the way this one turned out so I hope you do too alright. Let's take a look
save me the
Colors, they won't stop
bright, beautiful colors flashing
expanding piercing red green blue an endless
kaku
funny of meaningless noise the noise
It won't stop
violent grating waveforms
squeaking screeching
piercing sine cosine tangent
like playing a chalkboard on a turntable like playing a vinyl on a pizza crust an
endless poem of meaningless
load me
What
Load me
Save me load me
Save me and load me
That is really strange
hmm
It's even more abstract than your last one, huh?
I'm gonna say
What the fuck?
Haha, I guess. It's just the way I write. I'm sorry if you don't like it no
I never said that it's just a kind of thing. I never really seen before I guess I
kind of like playing with my space on that paper is aware that I would love to join this club and actually write poetry I
Kind of like playing with my space on the paper
Choosing where and how to put space words can totally change the mood of the poet
It's someone's like magic the way I wrote the lines really short makes it feel like they're trying to speak over the noise I see
It's still hard for me to tell what it's about though
Sometimes asking what a poem is about isn't the right question a poem can be abstract as a physical expression
Or of a feeling or a conversation with the reader so putting it that way not every poem is about something anyway
Here's Monica's writing tip of the day yay
Sometimes you'll find yourself facing a difficult decision when that happens don't forget to save your game
You never know when you might change your mind or when something unexpected may happen
Wait is this tipping even though about riding what I'm Haven talking about. Haha. That's my advice for today. Thanks for listening
Okay everyone we're all done reading each other's poem right?
I have something extra planned today, so if everyone could come sit at the front of the room. This is about the festival
well sort of
Do we really have to do something for the first of all?
It's not like we can put together anything good in just a few days
Well, we'll just end up embarrassing herself instead of getting any new members
That's a concern of mine as well. I don't really do well with last-minute preparation
Don't worry so much. We're going to keep it simple. Okay? We won't need more than a few decorations
Sarah has been working on posters, and I've designed some pamphlets we can keep on during the event
Okay, that's great at all, but that doesn't tell us what we're actually going to be doing
believin ah
Sorry, I thought you heard about it already. We're going to keep we're going to be performing
performing right
Monica
Yeah, we're going to have be having a poetry performance each of us is going to choose a poem to recite during the event
but the cool part is we're also going to let anyone else come up and recite poems to
Say always putting in all the posters in case anyone wants to prepare ahead of time. Oh he's putting it in the older project
Sarah's been coloring a
Poster holds it up for us to see
Are you kidding me Monica?
You didn't you didn't already start putting those posters up. Did you?
And well, I did
Do you really think it's bad if that bad of idea?
Well, no it's not a bad idea, but I didn't sign up for this you know
there's no way I'm going to be performing in front of a group of people like that I
Agree with Natsuki I could never in my life do something like that imagine it Yuri shakes her head in fear
No, sorry I understand where they're coming from
Remember that Nats the King Yuri never show their pawns with anyone until just a couple days ago
It's a lot of them. It's a lot to ask for them to
recite their poems out loud to a
whole roomful of people I
Guess I kind of overlooked that so I'm sorry but
I still think we should give it our best
we're the ones responsible for the fate of this club if we start the event and
Each other put on a good if we start the event and each put on a good performance
Then it will inspire others to do the same and the more people who perform the better
We'll be able to show everyone that what literature Lee club is all about
It's a bit expressing your feelings
Being intimate with your same friend and everything and having pain
That's right, and it's those reasons that we're all in this club today
Don't you want to share that with others?
To inspire them to find the same feelings that
Brought you here in the first place
I know you do I know we all do and
If all it takes is standing in front of a room for two minutes and reciting a poem then I know you can do it
Matt Suki and Yuri remain silent Sayuri looks worried I guess that leaves me no choice I
agree, I don't think it's too much to ask I
Think that's a Orion Monica
I've been trying really hard to get new members the least we can do is help them out a little bit
It looks like Matt Sookie doesn't have any arguments laughs
Okay, thank
For Yuri though, that's gonna kill her. I guess I'll just have to get it over with
Be very roof. Thanks NAT segi
What about you Yuri?
Yuri, dejectedly glances run at everyone else's expected faces I
Guess I don't really have any choice. Have a choice
You're the best Siri
This club is seriously going to be the death of me oh
Gosh you'll be fine Yuri, but anyway. Let's move on to their main event I
Want each of you to choose a poem of yours we're going to practice reciting them in front of each other?
No, wait
Monica
This is too sudden
Well if you can't recite your poem in front of the club. How do you expect to do it in front of strangers? Oh?
No, don't worry
I'll start to help everyone feel a little bit more comfortable
humanics
Of course now. Let's see
Monica flips through her notebook - to the specific poem she has in mind for herself
then she then stands behind the podium the title of this poem is the
Way they fly I wonder if it will be another weird
breaking the fourth wall
kind of thing a hen
Monica begins reciting her plans her clear confident voice fills the room more than that her inflection is pristine
She knows exactly how to apply emotion behind each line
She recites bringing the words to life is this something she's done before or is she simply a natural. I glanced around me
Everyone has their eyes on Monica Saira looks amazed URI has an intense expression on her face that I don't understand
Finally Monica finisher there the recite
recitation the four of us applaud
Monica takes a deep takes a breath and smiles
Hey, that was so good Monica. Thank you very much. I was just hoping to set a good example
Are you ready to go next say hurry?
I'll go next
What URIs fighter that bully Stephen Yuri clashes a sheet of paper between her hands and Santa?
Keeping her head down. She walks quietly quickly over to the podium
This poem is called
Yuri, anxiously glances at each of us you can do it Yuri
so precious
It's
Called after image of a crimson. Eye
Yuri's voice shakes as she starts reading the poem
Just a moment ago
She practically refused to do to this why is she suddenly putting in so much effort as
Yuri gets past the first couple lines her voice changes
It's almost like what happens when you read gets absorbed absorbed into her books
Her quivering words transform into sharp syllables of a fierce and confident woman
That's my girl the poem is full of twists and turns into a structure that she
onion
Unity 8ye, and none Shu eighths I think I've seen that word written before with perfect timing
This must be a rare glimpse into her the whirling fire Yuri keeps concealed inside her head suddenly
She's finished everyone is stunned Yuri snaps back into reality and glances around him
She is as if she bewildered even herself
Hi
It's up to me to save this situation
I'm the first one to start applauding everyone joins me afterwards and we give Yuri their recognition she deserves
It's not that we didn't want to applaud for her
But we were call it so up guard that
We must have forgotten as we plot Yuri holds a poem to her chest and rushes back into her seat Yuri
That was really good. Thank you for sharing
This day is so much longer than the first two looks like Yuri is down for the count
Okay, I get them mixed in
so he helps out of her chair and
Cheerfully walks to the podium. This one is called my meter
Sorry a geek oh, yeah, sorry
How did you get a stereo easily, huh?
Try not to think of it like you're reciting to other people
Imagine you were a setting it to yourself like in front of a mirror or in your own head is
Your poem so it'll come out the best that way
ATAC okay then Sarah begins her porn somehow it feels like her soft voice was made as a perfect match
The poem isn't aimlessly cherry likes a aureus
It's serene and bittersweet if I were to read this on paper. I probably wouldn't think much of it
But hearing it come from Sayuri's voice almost give it a whole new meaning
Maybe this is what she meant when she said she likes my poems
It's like I get to reach me more deeply into someone. I thought I knew through and through
Sarah finishes and we applied I did good job, Sayuri
What does that even mean
It came right now so nicely Sayuri
The atmosphere of the poem fits you really nicely
But it might be that other poems wouldn't work quite as well with that kind of delivery
It really indeed in other words. I've seen poems and viewers with
Where that sort of gentle delivery wouldn't work as well?
They might need a love more force behind than depending on what you're reading
Oh, I see what you mean this will I be practicing big candy things? It's just embarrassing to do it in front of everyone
Next time I'm going to make you pick a poem that challenge you challenges you a lot more
We don't have much time before the festival you know
Okay, now who's next Natsuki
Don't make me go before PCB. It's not like I can compare to you guys anyway Wow
- we'll get P D by P G pile or everyone see this a little before ever
It's it's fine it's fine
I might as well get it over with but it's not like I have much of a selection of what to read
I just have to go with what I wrote today. I
Stand up and step in front of the podium
Everyone has their eyes on me making me feel terribly awkward. I recite my poem since I'm not exactly confident in my own writing
It's hard to put energy into it despite that once I finish I receive applause anyway
Sorry, I'm not really as good as everyone else
Don't worry about it so much. I think it's less about your abilities and more about your lack of confidence in your writing
That's something that that'll improve over time though. Yeah, maybe alright, then that just leaves you netsuke
I'm doing netsuke big grudgingly gets out of her seat and makes her way to the podium
The poem it's cold. It's cold. Why are you looking at me?
Because you're presenting
Anyway from the culture. That's a key. That's a key takes a breath once
she started reciting the poem her sour attitude disappears too long while she's still all an
Unfused her poem has a rhythm and rhyme to it
It's not Sookie's trademark style, and it works surprisingly well when spoken aloud
The words feel like they bounce up and down, and I said giving life to the pawn Natsuki finishes
And everyone applauds she helps back to her seat
That wasn't so bad was it you see pretty to see oh
You better not make me do that again? Ah well
Do you at least feel prepared enough to recite a poem in front of other people?
I mean doing it in front of other people will be way easier. I can put on whatever face
I want for other people, but when it's just my friends. It's just embarrassing
This is a bracelet you keep I think it would be the other way wait for me
Well, well, this is how it is - well. I guess in that case
You won't have much to worry about the festival
That said I want to thank everyone for coming through it might be hard
But I hope you all have an idea what it's like now
Make sure you pick a poem and get enough practice before the festival ok
I'll be making pamphlets so let me know ahead of time will you'll be reciting jeez I?
Should probably find some other poem to residance then that's fine, too
Doesn't have to be your own. I'm already pleasantly surprised that you're putting in all this effort for the club
it makes me really happy ah
Yeah, no problem
Ok everyone. I think that's about it for today
I know the festival is coming up, but let's try to write poems for tomorrow as well
It's been working out really nicely so far so I'd like to continue that as for the festival
We'll finish planning tomorrow, and then we'll have the weekend to prepare
Monday's the big day
I
Can't do this. I can't I can do this. I can do this all right I
Stand up. There's no way I'll be able to find some enthusiasm as Sayuri and Monika
but I'll do my best to get through it if it's for the sake of the club and
Impressing Monika, then I'll have to do my best what so I care about Monica the most
All ready to go Sayuri yep
Look at you two always go at home like that
It's kind of adorable isn't it yeah? She's guys
That make such a big deal out of it it must be a little nice though
well
How am I supposed to respond to that it's the KPG, but you don't have to feed
whatever, let's just go in go already I
Walk home with Sayuri once more even though. It's only been a few days a lot of things
I've already changed, but today say always being a little quieter than usual on the way home. Hey, sorry sorry
We're speaking you oh
No wonder
Um I would thinking about something familiar like how we get to I mean
If I are a phoneless with her words
So let's just say that Wendy Yuri asked to come with you oh
She's jealous, huh?
Where did you?
What kind of question is that?
You've got a putting me on the spot
Okay, yeah
I'm gonna lie to her. I mean obviously I would walk home with you everybody I
Would walk home with Siri just to make her happy
You really think I would ditch you for URI a
Bit bit she's so beautiful, it's me jeez I
Already see her in the club every day besides you always seem to really like going home together. I wouldn't just ruin that for you
You're so sweet. Bgp. They think it brought me to my 15
He would deserve it if he wanted it to
Sorry, I already made up my mind. I really can't figure you out sometimes. Sorry
Besides, what's the point of speculating something? That's never gonna happen
hmm
The conversation trails off it's kind of weird the thing that Sarah
For Sarah to care so much about but I want to respect her and keep her happy, too
Then again the festival is only a few days away who knows what will happen in that time
Okay
That makes for another day I'm gonna save over this one
Thank you for watching another episode of Doki Doki
Literature club, it was literally my pleasure.i
time flight flew by by this one
Jesus I went so fast
really, enjoying this we have been seeing some elements of breaking the fourth wall we know something is gonna change most likely at the
festival I
Can did spoil a little bit said that on day 4 is when it really gets weird?
Which is the next one so we're just gonna have to see what happens then
Thank you for leaving a like and showing all the support that you do
I really really really appreciate it, and I'm really glad I'm able to play this for you guys on YouTube. That's it. See you tomorrow
squad fan